[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
hey here we are dude
episode whatever it is uh
of congratulations and you know how we
do it here
don't
push me dude a lot of stuff going on in
the world
trying to move me on over but we got the
merch
in effect looks really nice with the dmx
chain got to take some links out of this
[ __ ] if i take some links out it'll look
like a little bit like a choker be
really nice
you know got the hat which is
really really that nice that nice
americana vibe and dude just like need
to take these
links out and just keep it like really
you know what i mean if i get the links
out i get the choker going on just with
the don't push me jesus christ the drip
is intense oh come on dude
absolutely ridiculous come on dude
well the drip is absolutely fantastic so
um yeah man we're doing it uh we got
another episode here congratulations get
your merch don't push me and all the
other stuff at crystallia.com that's
what we're doing um and we got the other
merch two go medium sometimes stay out
make friends in the comments and all
that other [ __ ] life rips we keep on
restocking it we're doubling it doubling
and we keep doubling it until they kill
me that's what happens
um we got an added show in irvine
because it's selling out baby so we
added another one
uh go to crystallia.com to go get
tickets to irvine we added one on the
thursday before that dude what what can
we say you want to fill the seats so
we're going to keep adding them and
we're going to keep doubling until they
kill me
um and then we also got another show
coming up you know your boy's starting
to venture out there right he's starting
to kind of just venture out there and
see what he does but he's not doing it
trepidatiously even though it seems like
he might be
he's not though dude because he's
following he's firing on all s
uh what do we say syllables
so we got a don't tell anybody dude
but we got a gig coming up in phoenix
and i'm not telling you when yet because
i'll drop the date soon
but it's going to be april 30th
and that's when it's going to be and
it's not going to be on my website yet
but be ready dude because it will sell
out and phoenix i know you know you like
to come out and see your boy i know you
like to come out and see your boys so
i'll be there in phoenix so just be
ready when i drop this [ __ ] i'm going to
drop it soon and when i drop it
get the tickets dude they'll sell stuff
very quickly but i'm teasing it
you know me i'm teasing it a little bit
i'm just showing you a little bit of
skin so crystallia.com keep checking
back for that and also irvine at his
show and that's what we do it and then
the merch don't push me you know what i
mean that's what we do we wear merch to
the shows we do
um and more importantly we wear my we
wear crystal merch to other people's
shows because that's really the gangster
[ __ ] um
and that's it dude
i will tell you though i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired of hearing about the
goddamn show euphoria so that's good
yeah dude oh yeah oh really euphoria oh
yeah dude
euphoria man can't go anywhere without
hearing about euphoria all right man
want to watch a show about [ __ ]
zendaya
wanna watch a drake show about zendaya
hey eufori you use more purple
hey euphoria dude when i just see clips
from euphoria it feels like i'm on drugs
it's
by design
two tonally two tonally purple
euphoria
who produced it drake
me me walking out of a [ __ ] viewing
party of euphoria bye guys
before it starts i'll i'll check you
later guys oh it's good oh really it's
good all right cool dude i don't watch
this [ __ ] you shove down my throat i
don't watch the [ __ ] you shoved up i
don't watch the [ __ ] dude i i can't why
i i mean dude here's the deal man i i
actually like hbo i think hbo makes some
ball in that [ __ ] but god damn it dude
if they make another [ __ ] show about
some euphoria is actually not this way
but they they really do be making some
friendship i mean they really do be
making some friendship dude hollywood is
[ __ ] failing they are trying so hard
to appease the fringe [ __ ]
that all the people who have regular
eyeballs are just like i don't what do i
i just want to watch a guy shoot someone
i i just want to watch a family argue
but it's like some [ __ ] ali it's got
to be about some like
in a small town a trans alien comes to
visit
eat barb what
and then everyone's like hmm
this is every hbo show they cut
something happens and then somebody cut
they cut to somebody going like this
but it's a drama
dude
it's a drama i get it when it's like the
office and [ __ ] when somebody's like hey
yeah and then someone's like uh
but hbo dude they make those but it's a
drama
dude
somebody will walk in i'll be like oh
i'm sorry i
critically acclaimed
stutterville
from the makers of um
comes
stutterville hi i uh
a trans alien from a small town in iowa
stutterville meeporp
from the makers of um
and why if you uh
from the makers of why if you uh
and um
comes
stutterville
things are so [ __ ] awkward that we
only put the cameras on the guys who
aren't talking
we have to film their reactions
critically acclaimed already even though
it's not out and only nine people watch
it
comes
stutterville
about somebody who's obese but we
pretend like they're healthy
stutterville
from a short-haired woman i think comes
stutterville
it's like all right i'll watch i don't
want to watch it dude
i don't want to watch it
put a gun in a vampire's hand and have
them blast away
i'll watch it
put a dragon with a [ __ ] heroine
problem
flying out of a burning building
i'll watch it
from the makers of
oh from the from the producers of the
cameras filming the wrong guys
[Laughter]
comes
from the director of
comes
i mean dude it's lost souls
in a [ __ ] it's just like dude i don't
want to watch it though dude this is
what i'm talking about don't push me man
don't push me i gotta sit there and
watch this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just it
and i like hbo
i mean dude
how can nine people watch it and this is
why hollywood's failing because they're
pushing that [ __ ] and of course
uh it's a sniffing an agenda
smelling an agenda
and you know i'm sniffing it out i'm a
[ __ ] doberman pincher on this [ __ ]
you got an agenda i'm a doberman okay
i smell it all right and i smell this
agenda
and so it's like
so now i got you know and and hollywood
well nobody's watching the [ __ ]
oscars or the emmys anymore because god
damn it did you see who's hosting it
[ __ ] amy schumer like who even
[ __ ]
like dude it's that's so 2 000 and
[ __ ] 16. they always get the person
that was like hot and too hot four year
five years ago to po you're late
hollywood you're [ __ ] late dude
you're late
you know that's why every show right now
is about blm blm was so [ __ ]
2019 it's unfucking believable dude
hollywood's late oh you have a show with
brandy in it now
no one gives a [ __ ] that was so 2020.
and now it's like
now it's like the emmys and the [ __ ]
oscars are trying to catch up
and it's like dude you're too late and
now we gotta nobody's gonna watch the
oscars with [ __ ] amy goddamn schumer
and wanda sykes as the host
from the producers of
the oscars
this [ __ ] would have banged in 2017.
jesus christ for [ __ ] sake why don't
you get george hamilton and a razor
scooter to host it
it's so [ __ ] ridiculous dude
brought to you by aol
i mean for [ __ ] sake dude brought to
you by someone who used to rule land in
[ __ ] 1600 dude it's so old nobody
gives you [ __ ] and then they keep
pumping out this [ __ ] to [ __ ] you
know to make
10 000 people happy and then they and
then it's critically acclaimed and then
the oscars don't give a [ __ ] so they
give the awards to the people nobody's
watching this [ __ ] remember when they
were gonna put [ __ ] black panther in
for the best uh they were gonna have
black panther for because because the
[ __ ] the the agenda was trying to
[ __ ] push like oh well there's
finally a movie for black superheroes
and then they were trying to make it so
uh it won an award so it was like most
popular movie at the oscars and then
everyone was like this is [ __ ] it's
about art and then they took it back and
they walked back on it dude it's like
just do
first of all that was a good idea to
[ __ ]
give an award to the most popular movie
that's all the oscars should ever be the
oscar should be six minutes long and it
should be some [ __ ] tick tock star
and he should just be like hey guys this
is the oscar today the award goes no
nominees dude just a guy who comes out
with some stupid [ __ ] back of a
duck's ass hair in the front
with some [ __ ] idiotic dance move
with the [ __ ] uh what's that cardi b
song
hey guys it's the oscars
hey guys chillax it's the oscars we're
keeping it lit the winner of the oscars
is black panther that's it that's it and
then it's over dan on it
now
thanks for watching the oscars
and it can't be over three minutes long
because that's how long you got to make
a goddamn tick tock for dude it's
nobody's watching this [ __ ] and i gotta
from from the makers of
a woman in a small town with a flannel
on
comes
i'm i'm just like that's why all these
[ __ ] that's why these youtube you see
the talk to the kids my my buddy's got a
five-year-old and he's like are you on
youtube i'm like [ __ ] i've been
on nbc he goes what's that
what's nbc stand for [ __ ] new big
cocky
i mean come on dude they take lumps of
[ __ ] every week
new wednesday eight o'clock lumps of
[ __ ]
starring [ __ ] john cryer
lumps of [ __ ]
so anyway dude i don't want to watch it
i don't care
uh whatever dude it's like i don't know
man let's
i
or i gotta watch like the [ __ ] thing
that's hot on netflix like tinder
swindler and like it's uh and everyone
talks about it for a week and then it's
gone and i can't even talk about it on
the podcast because it's too late and
now i can't talk about tinder swindler
because everyone's already [ __ ]
talked about it because it's been a
[ __ ] week ago i tried to watch that
yeezy [ __ ] documentary genius or
whatever the [ __ ]
genius dude
mexican hey have you seen genius
hey you seen that union movie
dude [ __ ] yeah dude i didn't watch
[ __ ] genius
that's the other thing too it's like
we're celebrating kanye west when he's
literally telling people to [ __ ] kill
pete davidson and we're acting like
that's cool because he brings in [ __ ]
stacks of absolute gold that uh a
[ __ ] in a pyramid fashion that
reaches the sky but it's like dude if
this was anyone else you'd cancel them
man remember when chrissy teigen was
bullying that [ __ ] stoddard girl you
[ __ ] canceled her because she's not
as big as kanye west kanye yes wes is is
is leading the trolls he's got a [ __ ]
army the guy guy's got damn trumpet he's
leading [ __ ] trolls to a [ __ ] 28
year old guy on snl to go [ __ ] kill
him calling him skeet dude and you know
skeet davidson is [ __ ] bipolar
why aren't you canceling him because he
stacks money to the sky dude if you take
one thing away from this podcast right
how right now this one it's that nobody
gives a [ __ ] except for the dollar dude
the dollar is when people care
um
it's like dude i you know
by the way i saw tinder swindler do it
and that that guy [ __ ] got through it
he's got apparently he's got a hotter
check now
apparently he's got like an even like
the hot the guy leveled up dude nobody
gives a [ __ ] about anything the guy was
swindling to [ __ ] high heavens all
these different chicks by the way hey i
know i get it these chicks they're
they're victims from the tinder swindler
and the guys piece of [ __ ] but chicks
come on
hey dude also though stop and think
about stuff
oh yeah you gave him eighty thousand
dollars
and then gave him twenty thousand
dollars hey come on
stand up and wake up
what's going on dude
work with him work with work with
yourself
tinder swindler dude he's not even in
jail because technically he just
borrowed money dude you know how
gangster that is
[Music]
tindall
[Music]
swindle dude that's amazing man the guy
just was like and then she called and
she's like you're taking a lot of money
for me he's like listen [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] i have to do i have enemies
oh dude i have enemies there after me
[ __ ] give me more money or else i can't
fly away from my enemies
oh wake up girl
you're 30 though
oh real quick
okay i understand that you're a victim
but real quick
you're 30.
don't give anyone 20 grand
after you give them 80 grand you know
that old saying
don't give anyone 20 grand after you
give them 80 grand
how you getting swindled
oh dude i just i can't like just stop
and think though
right
because you're a person on earth
and everyone says that wouldn't happen
to me
but it would
but it wouldn't happen to me dude
not me
i got catfished one time when i was
really young nothing happened the girl
just didn't show up
and then i realized
and now they got [ __ ] all apps where
you can make sure if you find out
someone's [ __ ] catfishing here or
this and that goo how about
you google
if a guy
if you're giving someone 80 grand give
them a google
deal and then
hi i'm christolia from nbc's undateable
if you give a guy 80 grand
first of all stop and think before you
write that check
and give them a [ __ ] google you [ __ ]
[Applause]
and i do it myself
i sing it myself
i don't know how any i don't know i
don't know how anyone gets swindled
honestly
um
what i do know is that there's bigger
issues in the world like the war in
[ __ ] russia and ukraine and i know
nothing about it
everyone's just like dude the president
in ukraine is [ __ ] absolutely he's
got big balls and i'm just like okay
he's got big balls let's do it let's uh
let's just [ __ ]
let's just be on his side who knows
what's going on but let's be on his side
right who [ __ ] knows i have no clue
all i know is he used to do stand-up
comedy so i'm on board man and the guys
on the front line apparently it's so
funny that what's his name [ __ ] putin
is like by the way his last name is
putin
which means farting
the only [ __ ] more name
that is
absolutely i can't believe a last name
is [ __ ] alex pujols alexander what's
his name
pujols alexander pujols
alex pujols
whatever it is albert pujols dude poo
holes
hey dude
that's your last name might as well be
anus
albert anus
poo holes dude
two of them albert anuses
albert to anus
albert
that's your name dude anyway putin
p-o-o-t-i-n is basically saying uh that
he's like hey they he fled dude putin is
he's just like you know he fled
and then the guy's like okay the
ukrainian president is like gotta put
out a social media he's like no look i'm
right here man i'm on the front lines
and putin's just like no you fled
and they thought that they were going to
clean up this [ __ ] in ukraine
immediately but they didn't do they even
got him surrounded and the [ __ ]
ukrainian [ __ ] will dude the
ukrainian will dude
they just stood there like some trees
dude
the will that ukraine got man just abs
we're not moving
fought a guy from ukraine once in uh
when i used to do uh jiu jitsu and that
honestly trying to fight that guy oh no
never mind he was croatian
never mind i'm racist
um
[Music]
so yeah
russians don't [ __ ] around though dude
did you see that one video where the
tank just ran over a civilian car like
jesus christ man
how sad
just so [ __ ] up man
um
let's look at this [ __ ] man
i can't believe this is a real thing
you guys know who anneline mccord is
she is uh was on this the re
new uh what do you call 90210 show that
came out a while ago i mean she's got to
be in her 30s now but i mean no she's
definitely in her 30s
this is the thing this is the new uh
what was the new one where everyone was
saying they were racist or something the
wonder woman won in black and white
where she was like i'm racist and i
shouldn't be and will ferrell oh imagine
it was they saying imagine imagine all
the people
[Music]
and they were just [ __ ] saving the
world you know you had [ __ ] cyclops
from the first x-men just like
just shoot out your eye beams bro
we're good
just shoot out your eye beams instead
imagine all the people
[ __ ] the israeli
what's her name wonder woman hey just
rope up somebody in your invisible plane
how about that that's fine
living
what's his name john lennon just rolling
over in his grave
oh this isn't what i wanted
what the [ __ ] are these idiots doing
dirt all over him in his [ __ ] coffin
what the [ __ ] are they doing
i wish that guy didn't shoot me so i
could still be alive and ring these
[ __ ] necks
it's so
like these celebrities the [ __ ]
hollywood's done dude
so anyway they did that and now
as apparent you know apparently ellen
mccord didn't understand how much fun
that was making fun of about everything
what was the other one was that the only
one there was another one too where it
was like we're all racist where the girl
from [ __ ] uh
um
the oj movie and the or the oj show or
the [ __ ] american history
no american horror story girl was like
where i'm racist i'm sorry for my
[ __ ] privilege oh [ __ ] shut up man
you know
i'm so tired of hearing about [ __ ]
privilege
here we go
so she decided elin mccord this white
chick decided to make a [ __ ]
poem to to
vladimir putin
there's one thing i know for sure
nobody named vladimir ever read a poem
they don't give at least now maybe in
like the [ __ ] 1400s poetry was
probably like tick-tock back then and
they were just like hey we have and the
older generation was like [ __ ] this
poetry it's about stabbing enemies
it's about impaling your enemies and
they are out here writing words
[ __ ] them art is nothing impale your
enemies face
but now dude you got white chicks out
here thinking guys named vladimir give a
[ __ ] about [ __ ] floral words
some chick from 90210 just here we go
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
imagine
like just saying that to somebody just
that you met oh i'm sorry hey dude hey
i'm sorry i'm sorry i wasn't your dad
you wouldn't have been like this bro
i mean
you'd wipe that guy's
face all over the pavement you know and
this chick
because she's some [ __ ] here we go
actress if i was your mother you would
have been so loved
held in the arms of joyous light never
would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
let me tell you one thing too
don't rhyme
okay
don't rhyme
rhyming sucks
anyone rhyming it's so corny
even rappers like what are you doing
yeah [ __ ] i kill people oh
really yup and i rob yep oh really yeah
dude yeah i kill my [ __ ] and i rob
and i fight constantly really
yup
bacon shaking
oh that's corny dude
yeah avondo oh you rob and kill and
rhyme
rhyming's corny also there's people who
are much better at it like [ __ ]
eminem you know
and kendrick lamar and this chick from
90210 is like unfurled
unfurled and uncurled and unjurled
unworld and unfurled and unjurald
the second you put the word demise
[Laughter]
in a in a in a poem you know it's bad
until my demise
until i [ __ ] die i don't like this
floral language until i die
and until i until my untimely demise and
i'm blindly
saving the world dude
a nation sitting peaceful under a night
sky if i was your mother
the world would have been warm oh does
she have kids i need to know this
anna
lynn
mccord
uh
children
spelled it wrong
does she have kids
oh she does
looks like she does
cute
cute
okay well whatever i don't know if she
does or not she's holding kids in this
though so i guess it's her thing so much
laughter and joy and nothing would harm
i can't imagine the stain the soul
stealing pain that the little boy you
must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you lived in a cruel unjust world
you know what sucks man is like now that
like
i know what it's like to be shamed and
stuff like i just feel bad
i used to think it was so funny and i do
for a little bit and then i stop and i
think oh
this sucks for her everyone's coming
after her
we love you anna lynn mccord we do here
at congratulations and i hope you figure
it out and honestly if poetry is the
career you want to move to i wish you
all the best and i'm not even joking
but you can't save the world with a poem
i you know i know poets would be like
but yes you can but okay but you can't
though right
what's up with this [ __ ]
if i was your mother
if i was your father
i'd yell at you i'd yell at you a lot
because things things would make me so
pissed off that you did that's my poem
if i was your father vladimir
you probably would hate me so much cause
i'd be so mad your name was vladimir and
that your mom chose that name because
that name isn't good
vladimir if i was your father
um
here's another thing that happened which
i mean i get is right now i have a
question is rick ross just is he does he
watch congratulations
because the guy just keeps pumping out
new videos every week and i feel like
he's speaking to us
babies
i feel like he's speaking to us remember
when he did the piano that played
himself and then he was and then we made
fun of it and then he bought a cow and
then we made fun of it and now he's
doing this
chopping trees down
hey rick ross
do you listen to my podcast
hey rick ross real quick do you listen
to my podcast or are you just that
lonely
here we go right here
morning glory i'm up early this morning
and i just got my estimate i got like
tea trees
first of all tin trees had no idea when
i first heard this what he was talking
about i was like how many trees is that
i thought he said three
then i realized he's saying 10.
when it cut down
they say them big trees them big oak
trees rose imagine dude
i have 10 trees i want to come down
i want to cut down well then big trees
them big oak trees
rose
i said i don't care
i want them cut down them i'm [ __ ] up
this bob right there [ __ ] told me a
thousand dollars a tree for 10 trees
that's 10 000. okay i just told my homie
you go to home depot and you go get me
the biggest [ __ ] saw there is
with a big chain and you crank that
[ __ ] imma cut the trees down
dude
i had the worst childhood
you know
had to say big chain because he's a
rapper like that's not the [ __ ] dude
get it get it get us all get a big soap
get the biggest saw with a big chain
i mean
also
you you here's the other thing about
this you were only bragging about how
you have money and now i get it you're
saying how cool you are that you could
cut down trees but also you're bragging
about
not having to spend money eat cheapskate
now
so here we go
you heard me
he must have forgot who the [ __ ] i am
yeah i'm hands-on i cut down my own
[ __ ] trees you can't charge the
boss a thousand dollars a tree to cut it
down i cut down my own [ __ ]
trees i gotta make room for my animals
also there was a [ __ ] outfit change
in the middle of those stories which is
great he could be put on a completely
different hoodie and a [ __ ] uh cowboy
hat you must have forgot who i was i cut
down trees oh sorry you never said god
how annoying would it be to be this
guy's [ __ ] friend for real you'd just
be like stop yelling bro yeah but i
gotta cut down trees okay
just hire someone they tried to they
tried to but but the thing is they tried
to
charge the boss ten thousand dollars to
cut down ten trees okay that's a
thousand dollars a tree okay
yes so
right
did they forget who i was
no i i don't really understand
they probably forgot who i was because i
wouldn't show them id
i wouldn't show them id the last time
they tried to drop off a package
remember that's why they forgot who you
are [ __ ] you don't show them the
goddamn ideas when they're trying to
give you jewelry
boss we gotta get back to nature
that you know what he was right he did
say you got to get back to nature now
he's cutting down his own trees here we
go
so dangerous
so dangerous
wow
[Music]
so dangerous
chased after the cameraman with the
chains
oh my god so dangerous
he was running oh don't be a fat guy
running with a chainsaw
tripped a little bit you know over the
leaves a branch broke when he was wow
dude who's filming it for real who's
filming it like anybody you think of is
funny
like just his buddy [ __ ] hilarious uh
because you know he doesn't you know man
i don't know if this is going to be the
best idea
his mom hilarious a kid of his hilarious
uh his butler hilarious
uh excuse me mr uh mr ross rose excuse
me mr rose are we doing anything
absolutely [ __ ] terrible today
boss
right but are we doing anything
absolutely [ __ ] atrocious today
that depends what was the estimate on
the tree thing
get a big chain
um
dude
this is so good
jay dempsey
john dempsey
posted on
uh
instagram right yeah
a meme
i mean dude
i mean
this whole thing
this is the greatest
this is the greatest story ever told
and you could tell it in two minutes
like there have been novels written
like that took authors like years to
write and edit and get down and figure
out i mean the godfather is considered
the greatest movie of all time there is
no story that's greater that has ever
been told than the firing
of
john dempsey
estee lauder senior executive john
dempsey has been fired after posting
this meme on instagram he was making
nearly 10 million a year
he posted an apology saying he didn't
read it before
posting okay
well don't do that
senior executive
and the [ __ ] meme
was
first of all it i where do i even start
to okay so it's a book by sesame street
i guess and the title of the book is my
and then n word
snuffy done got the rona at a chingy
concert
and dude it has
big bird with a mask on
and
snuffleuphagus in bed with a thermometer
in his mouth
[Laughter]
first of all that meme
is [ __ ] hilarious
it's just hilarious
and he got he posted it
it dude it's got the asterisks in the
n-word so it doesn't say n-word but dude
the ceo or whatever of s day lauder
posted it dude
don got the ronda at a changi concert
dude
chingy
was there ever a worse
was that him or was that [ __ ]
was that nelly dude nelly basically is
chick i love how chingy came out only
because nelly came out
nellie was like ha anne and chili chingy
[Laughter]
chingy just
rose up from the [ __ ] womb hello
i am here now
i'm here right where right her i like
the way you move it right her that was
him
right there wherever do it her there
doesn't matter it's equally as stupid i
like the way you move it right there
savage
concert i know one thing if ching is
still doing concerts you definitely
can't get the rona there because there's
a one person there
chingy
[Laughter]
dude
imagine being shitty
[Applause]
dude imagine being chingy and
and the amount of times people say hey
do right there
do the right there's trying to come up
with new music and everyone's like no no
no do the one kind the one do the one
that only came out because there was a
nelly
how many y'all got the rhona out there
dude this is unreal dude that this guy
got fired for posting this this is
hilarious this is so stupid dude cancel
culture is so [ __ ] idiotic this meme
is [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] you if you don't think so
snuffy dun got the rona at a chingy
concert it says it's all dude it's all
the [ __ ] artwork dude the thermometer
under his trunk
and big bird has a [ __ ] mask on
oh [ __ ] like he's taking care of him one
of those heat pad bottle things on the
top of his head
wow chingy what's he doing now
worst name too dude chingy
are they going to come after me like
they came after when i started making
fun of a [ __ ] busy bone does chingy
have that fan base too
busy bone they made a [ __ ] they wrote an
article about me man look at chingy here
we go chingy let's see what he's up to
let's look at the wikipedia
chingy edward earl bailey jr oh he's
you're telling me his real name isn't
chingy okay is an american rapper record
producer and actor they're all record
producers dude if you're a rapper and
you don't have a record produce if you
don't you don't have a company you ain't
[ __ ] dude
um
chingy's 2003 debut album jackpot sold
two million copies dude that is
astounding
you can't even sell any copies now
because it's all streaming this is
astounding thanks to the boost from
right there a second album powerball and
was released 2004 to mix
reviews and his 2006 release hood star
spawned the hit single
pulling me back featuring tyrese dude
tyrese and chingy on a song you know eh
2006.
featuring domain jermaine dupree uh
sir 2007.
dude
his fourth album hater love it was
released under disturbing the piece
preceded by lead single fly like me
featuring amory a studio album success
and failure was released 2010.
in 2018 he made his official debut as a
record producer with his single sparks
fly which debuted on march 4th 2018.
dude i blame him for the pandemic
um
so what's he been doing now
signing the bungalow records
chingy in 2021
chingy headlined a tour
in the united states with r b singers
maya and genuine dude changi headlined
with with genuine
remember genuine jump on it dude genuine
come to it
yep what yep dude if you had an and if
you had a [ __ ] accurate integra you
[ __ ] bumped that song so hard yeah
yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
dude one fire said are you singing pony
[ __ ] yeah i am dude come run it let's do
it
me up
yup yup yup dude
oh how could you listen to [ __ ] any
other [ __ ] [ __ ] poc when we do
let's do it right at my pony wait what
did he say doesn't he say i'm honey dude
singing i'm horny
[Laughter]
sir late 90s
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] do what i want man be up
be up
yeah
i'm honey dude i didn't know he sung i'm
horny until like three years ago when i
found that out
i wasn't chris dalia anymore
that's how much it took me out dude i
just immediately became someone else
that's how much it [ __ ] me up
i was immediately just i don't know i
can't believe that [ __ ]
dude i cannot believe that genuine first
of all his name is genuine
w-i-n-e he doesn't even spell it genuine
and [ __ ]
he sings i'm a horny dude
and like they'd play it at like bar
mitzvahs
jews would just be like [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
just [ __ ] doing body rolls yarmulkes
flying off yup
yup i'm honey just a [ __ ] jewish dad
just like you're a man now son let's do
it i'm horny might as well be like got
boners
i mean dude it's so crass to sing i'm
horny dude they played this [ __ ] at
[ __ ] birthday parties like seriously
they played it at bar mitzvahs dude i'm
honey got boners gonna stick them in
[ __ ]
my saddle
that's a [ __ ]
saddle
means [ __ ]
just so [ __ ]
right
my pony my pony means penis
it means
hard penis
dude
1999. if timbaland didn't do that beat i
will literally [ __ ] a guy
like straight up
he did it for sure i'm not even looking
it up no matter what he did it even if
he didn't do it he did it changi
right there dude how much did chingy
only always wear oversized [ __ ]
football jerseys and he nev like no
matter where he was like at funerals he
came with a colts jersey on you know he
would [ __ ] i i at like his had like
his mom and dad's [ __ ] 50th wedding
anniversary he showed up in a drew bled
so [ __ ]
what
timbaland produced it [ __ ] yeah dude we
figured it out
[Music]
dude timberland really do be making
those be up
be up yup yup
wow that's amazing dude that's the thing
about r b it's gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ]
like god damn
like if if an r b song came out it was
called
[ __ ] i'm on your insides now i swear to
god it would be a it would be a hit
it would be a [ __ ] complete hit make
love to your insides i swear to god that
would be a [ __ ] hit making love to
your insides
outside and the music video is them like
outside
doing it doggy style
it's chingy and he's got a [ __ ]
oversized kfc uh
kansas city jersey i almost said kfc
jersey
[ __ ] worst football team ever
fried chicken
uh jesus christ i'm sweating
i mean dude snuffy got
[Laughter]
snuffy done got the rona at a chingy
concert
wow man oh my god dude cancel culture is
[ __ ] hilarious
that's the thing man you can get now
what is he gonna do he was making 10
million dollars a year jesus christ i
mean dude
he has to tell people that
oh what happened
[Laughter]
hey like people who don't know you know
hey what's up man how's it going dude
how's estee lauder oh i actually don't
work there anymore what happened what
you were like killing it there why are
you making like [ __ ] you're making like
10 million dollars a year
yeah i know i know i i just uh i didn't
work out really you quit
no uh they kind of forced my hand
why
well they were gonna fire me what
what happened this lay people off but
you're the senior executive yeah no no
no
um
i posted a meme uh with the n-word and
it said snuffy done got the rhone at a
chingy concert
oh
oh
ah
you remember that
you remember the you remember chingy
right
yeah yeah i do yeah
he had that one song right there right
there yeah right there yeah
it was right around the time
right around the time no nelly nelly
yeah yeah nelly came out
i actually don't even think that chingy
would probably have even been
uh
really famous if it wasn't for if it
wasn't for nelly yeah yeah yeah
anyway well
what are you going to do now
uh i think i'm going to start a meme
page
i'm honey
i mean my dad has listened to that song
you know
wow imagine my dad meeting genuine
hey bill there's no way
[Laughter]
dude there's no [ __ ] [ __ ] way
that genuine doesn't sound like this hey
bill how's it going
[Laughter]
dude hell yeah dude
oh thank you to the valet guy giving him
his keys back
[Laughter]
thank you for keeping it close
[Laughter]
dude the valet guy pulls up the song be
up b-o-b
thank you for keeping it close isn't
that ironic that song is playing
that's my song
i think i'm horny in it
[Laughter]
dude holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ]
god damn it
oh my god what do you what what more do
you want from me you know it's like this
is the podcast
oh god damn it i'm sweating
ah
ah
hi bill
dude i saw the [ __ ] uh i was watching
i was online earlier and i was watching
this thing this youtube pocket what's up
with al gore like how the [ __ ] why did
daniel craig's screen test for double 07
come up on my [ __ ] front page on
youtube you know
and it was cool and i was watching i was
watching it a little bit though i guess
i'm the sucker right and i was watching
it and they were doing it and
one of the producers was talking and she
was like
i don't want you know he didn't want to
do it he didn't want to do the
play james bond and then it was like
cutting to daniel craig talking and he
was like i didn't want to do it like you
know i i don't know i was like hey
they'll send me the script i'm sure i'll
read it and i won't want to do it and
it's like
these [ __ ] actors dude are like you
don't want to be james bond like even if
you
even if you hate it
what do you what are you like dude
there's construction workers out there
there's like [ __ ] there's i mean
hooker is a job
like just do it
eat it
and then do whatever you want be a
[ __ ] hundred millionaire
chingies out there you know what i mean
big hey guy be james bond for a decade
sorry
but like then do whatever the [ __ ] you
want it's so funny these actors are like
i don't know if i want to be i don't
know like you hear about guy i don't
want to be spider-man i don't want to be
or [ __ ] andrew garfield after one
spider-man like i don't know if this is
for me oh yeah just stay in it what are
you gonna do
tick tick boom what are you gonna do a
movie that matters on amazon prime who
gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] get those [ __ ]
monies get those monies and then do what
you want
it's so weird when actors are like no
i'm gonna actually
pass on that and then a year later come
out in a movie called like ghost house
with [ __ ] kate beckinsale and you're
like this is why you didn't want to be
[ __ ] batman
this movie sucks dick
i don't understand it
yeah i'm in a pass honestly i don't feel
like being captain america instead i
want to be uh i want to be
in the genuine autobio the biopic
i'm going to be genuine instead yeah no
i don't want to be the [ __ ] what's
his name
what was his name who is the [ __ ] uh
the captain america sidekick guy that
became captain america what's his name
falcon i don't want to be falcon i i'm
i'm going to play genuine
it's the biopic and a lot of people
don't know his story it's important for
me to tell it no one's going to see it
dude what's it called the biopic oh it's
called i'm horny
i'm horny let's do it meop
one man
you know what i mean they'd slow it down
right
one man
i'm so horny
hornier than ever
meow
hi guys
it's 1998 only
[Laughter]
there were no algorithms back in 1998
but if there was this song would have
been created through an algorithm
one man
[Music]
with a boner that touched the sky
[Laughter]
from the makers of hbos
um
one light-skinned black man with a
mustache that looks like pubes
comes
i'm horny
[Music]
this
summer squirt all over again
oh my god dude
i think this might be the best episode
of congratulations of all time just with
how much fun i'm having
and he stays drinking that iced
americano you know what dude
king of this thing in the wing is gonna
be something so sign up for that patreon
and also [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] it's on
babies it's [ __ ] on
and i got shows in irvine
coming up i added a show it's all sold
out you know how we do my babies we fill
the seats we keep those seats so warm oh
god damn it
oh is crystallia going to enter a
building is going to be speaking into a
microphone then guess what the
temperatures does of the seats go on
oh it would be hard to keep the sc it's
hard to keep the seats cool why because
people are always [ __ ] sitting in
them why because crystal leaves and
they're on god damn it
that's all good he's in the room dude
so anyway
is there one cold seat no
how did how did you make that happen oh
crystalia came by and spoke into a
microphone oh god damn it
we love warm seats oh god damn it
what was the temperature of the seat
98.6 degrees why because humans were in
them oh my god
uh anyway dude do we have misconnections
or no we don't have any what else can we
talk about let's talk about one more
thing
i know about 105 yeah that's true yep
let's look at this trailer here i want
to look at this for real
i remember this movie i remember that
and this is why when i look at this
trailer
congo 1995 since we're on a 1995 kick
this is
the official trailer to the movie congo
1995. okay tim curry's in it and one of
the things that i like about tim curry
is he is a fantastic actor okay now what
makes him a great actor one line he has
the greatest one line in history of
cinema i'm pretty sure it's in the
[ __ ] trailer here where he says i
didn't know what he said i had to watch
the trailer a few times and he says
wow i've only heard this once let's see
i've only heard this once in the theater
twice in the theater i went i heard it
once i didn't understand it then i saw
the preview again in another movie and i
realized what he said and this is what
he says this is what he says the same
hieroglyphics over and over again but
this is how he says it the same
ideographics over and over again and
when he did that he skyrocketed to my
number one actor of all time okay so
let's see if it's in the preview i
believe it is
it's a 95.
he's smoking a bomb
in the race for the world's most
advanced communications technology is
this a joke
a shocking discovery has been made what
was that lock your remote give me a
thermal reading result to 6-6
it will take two young scientists into
the heart of the african jungle
that i do secret hidden for 2 000 years
old
it was so the [ __ ] to have
[ __ ] wet curly hair in the 90s as a
white guy you used to work for the cia
and now you're traveling some will come
to it for science it's a big deal
charles this is a big fine some for
fortune a diamond mine of incredible
bounty wow that's temporary the diamond
mine of incredible bounty she belongs
here
together they will search my boss who
thought i wasn't gonna make it he sent
another expedition drawn deep into a
mystery commanded him he said destroyed
people dead what are you laughing at
this thing is a great gorilla i saw one
and the more they discovered there we go
same hieroglyphics over and over the
greatest [ __ ] he's got a good memory
dude he doesn't need [ __ ] kinkobaloma
at all man
[Music]
the same
ideologics over and over dude when he
did that
pow skyrocketed to the i mean dude [ __ ]
lawrence olivier this guy gets all the
oscars man wow what a great build up and
what a great crescendo to this [ __ ]
podcast man the same idiot over and over
dude unbelievable same hieroglyphics
over and over the greater the danger
almost choked the same ill glyphics over
and over again
is there anyone
watching you
busted came when he screamed
never saw an animal move like this
wow
by the author of jurassic park
where you are the endangered species wow
nice of course they really nailed that
preview huh
congo where you are the endangered
species
the same ill glyphics over and over
again
all right well that's good man you guys
we had a good time thank you for
listening to this episode of
congratulations remember don't push me
now what i'd like you to do is get down
there and just kind of
gently tap that like button and
absolutely obliterate that comic comment
section just make friends in the
comments you see people out there
commenting you write them back hey i'm
from orange county or hey i'm from
illinois
are you close you know what i mean go to
red robin
chill go to chrisleya.com irvine and i
got phoenix coming up my baby so be
ready for that hey guys that's it for
the episode on youtube if you'd like to
watch the full uncut version go on over
to our patreon and sign up patreon.com
not only will you get that you'll get it
ad free you'll get everything ad free
you'll get an extra episode a month and
all the backlog episodes that were only
on patreon and we do another thing
called review mode we got
behind-the-scenes footage to all my with
chris videos it's great man there's a
discord where we all chat on and uh go
on and check it out it's six dollars a
month
head on over bye-bye
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
he does definitely cut down trees